Brazil's president Louisiana
is in China to boost political and
economic ties with his nation's biggest
trading partner he arrived in Shanghai
for the inauguration of Brazil's former
president Dilma Rousseff as the head of
the new development bank that was set up
by Brazil Russia China India and South
Africa known as the brics a group of
emerging economies president Lula will
then head to Beijing where he was
expected to discuss the Ukraine war with
President Xi Jinping not Joseph Mahoney
is a professor of politics and
international relations at East China
Normal University he's joining us from
Shanghai thank you very much indeed for
being with us on Al Jazeera Brazil and
China do have very strong trading links
but how much leverage diplomatically and
politically does that give Brazil with
China
well we do know that uh that Lula is
wanting to re-engage uh that that
relations have gone a little bit off
track with his predecessor bolsonaro
um then there was some concern that
bolsonaro had really emphasized uh
agricultural raw materials these sorts
of things maybe at the expense of of
some of Lulu's interest more
manufacturing it is hard to compete with
selling manufactured goods in China
given that China has the most advanced
manufacturing system in the world but he
has obviously as you've noted the
interest in attending uh uh Dela
rousseff's inauguration they're they're
very close friends they're they're close
comrades
um and he clearly has his agenda with
with Ukraine uh wanting to support the
the efforts there uh as well as uh I
think to strike a balance uh uh with
Brazil between the United States and
China this follows of course his trip to
visit Biden and he's he's clearly making
some very powerful uh signals here that
that also run a little bit contrary to
what Washington would otherwise like to
hear in order to be obviously an
effective go between between
Russia and Ukraine he would have to talk
to Russia as well and how much influence
does he have with Russia compared to
that that he has perhaps with China
well I don't I don't think that that's
necessarily his objective I mean clearly
I think he he uh is envisioning uh a
global South uh effort where there would
be a number of countries from the global
South coming together to support uh this
type of uh effort to to find a
negotiated settlement this is why uh
he's uh been talking about it while he's
uh talking with uh China so I don't I
don't think that he necessarily
envisions uh Brazil taking the lead or
Brazil necessarily being the the primary
mediator with Russia uh that that would
probably be more suitable to to Beijing
but he does see it as a as a global
South uh LED effort where different
countries have different leverages that
that night that might be useful for
finding a diplomatic solution it's it's
going to be a bit of a Time Walk isn't
it for for Lila de Silva because as you
mentioned before he's trying to also
re-establish relations with the United
States that had gone awry under the
president under the leadership of jair
bolsonaro what is the US do you think
going to be watching from this visit
um that Lula is making to China what is
it going to be looking for to see how
that's going to play out
well I think one thing that they're
hoping is that he won't be as
inflammatory as president macron was on
his exit uh talking about Europe
avoiding becoming basil States uh Lula
you know is what we might call a legacy
leftist
um you know he he is uh very much
admired by by Business Leaders by Wall
Street uh he's a pragmatist uh clearly
he went to visit the United States now
he's come to China uh he wants uh he has
to acknowledge the fact that China is
Brazil's largest trading partner that
China invests more in Brazil than anyone
else and he's also very very committed
uh ideologically to the global South but
you know the the the certain images like
him in Shanghai visiting a Huawei uh
research uh laboratory uh is clearly
going to to play very poorly in
Washington which of course has demonized
Chinese technology and Huawei as well as
is the uh the deal to jointly construct
the the cvers six satellites this is a
clear high-tech deal that will certainly
irritate the United States and and all
the more so because it connects in a
certain sense to China's uh Space
Program which the US has uh made uh
illegal and for the US itself that brics
Coalition Brazil Russia India China and
South Africa it's been long been
positioning itself as an alternative to
a northern hemisphere organizations if
you like like the G7 for example what
are the signs that it is heading towards
that that is beginning to achieve that
goal
yeah
well you know I think one of the big
things that we're starting to see not
just with bricks but with other
countries is uh the outline uh uh not
not yet the reality and certainly I
don't think necessarily in the near term
but the outline of a new world order in
terms of Finance uh one of the other big
achievements here is that the two
countries are going to uh uh move
towards uh settlement and their
respective currencies uh and bypass uh
the dollar we're seeing uh similar
developments with other uh leading
economies even even in some cases uh
recently A A Deal between a French
company and and China uh uh the clearing
natural gas sale in RMB this is
um I think where the world is heading
and and Bricks clearly I think uh
especially with the the new development
Bank
um in tandem with the various other
major projects uh associated with it
including the Belt Road initiative this
is uh the the main thrust of where
things are going
Jose Mahoney it's really interesting to
get your thoughts on this and we
appreciate you being with user thank you
very much indeed
thank you